[Applause]
[Music]
imagine you have an annoying long-term
house guest
we'll call the guests pat
apologies if your name is pat all names
have been changed here to protect the
innocent
pat is a good person but pat has some
really bad habits
pat smokes pat eats too much especially
too much fatty food
pat rarely exercises
pat has a bad habit of watching tv until
very late at night
pat may leave dishes in the sink too
long often overnight
pat gets into arguments sometimes and
holds a real grudge when the argument
doesn't go well
deep down pat's a good person actually
pat doesn't intend to do any of these
behaviors they're just habits
in fact if you were to ask pat about
them pat would be the first person to
talk about wanting to change
pat doesn't want to be a bad house guest
this is just pat's behavior
now you don't want to go to a hotel and
get away from pat you don't want to kick
pat out of the house
pat has a lot of redeeming qualities and
pat is your guest
what you really want to do is to train
pat to alter pat's behaviors in such a
way that you can transform pat into a
good house guest someone you wouldn't
mind spending time with someone you
might even look forward to seeing
think about what you would do
how might you use the tools of cognitive
neuroscience to alter pat's behaviors
my overarching tip for this lecture is
to take this list of things this list of
methods that you could use to alter
pat's behavior
and then realize that the best way to
alter your own behaviors will be to use
them not on pat
but on you
i've talked a lot in this course about
how much of our behavior is dictated by
unconscious automatic processes in our
brain
our decisions about what to do what to
eat what to say even how to say it are
dictated largely by subconscious
processes processes over which we
usually exert little control
perhaps the best evidence for this comes
from studies demonstrating that our
conscious experience of choosing to do
something
typically comes after we start to do it
not before
it's not that we can't control our
behaviors indeed the point of this
lecture is that we can it's just that
most of the time we don't
over short spans of time by exerting our
conscious will we can immediately often
drastically alter our behavior but that
explicit control of behavior takes
continual attention a lot of mental
energy
as we get distracted by other things and
inevitably we always do
the conscious control drifts away as it
does the unconscious control takes over
again
this lecture is about ways you can
change the unconscious habits so that
even when you aren't paying attention
your unconscious mental systems will do
the things you'd like them to do
this house guest we're discussing
isn't just staying in your house
this house guest i want you to ponder
training lives in your head
okay let's get to a simple tip that's
really startlingly effective for
reducing the frequency of some bad habit
could be smoking could be unhealthy
snacking could be watching television
too much
even something like arguing with your
spouse over things that in retrospect
seem like pretty silly reasons for an
argument
let's aim our behavioral training at our
bad house guest pat
say pat had the bad habit what simple
thing would you do to try to stop it or
at least
have pat quit doing it so much
one simple thing you might try is to
call attention to the behavior whenever
it happens
pat you're eating all the cookies again
please stop
one additional step would be to write
down the times when this problem
behavior occurs
and then show that list at the end of
the day
a really simple and effective tip for
reducing your own habitual behavior is
to do this same thing
write it down whenever you do it
that's it
you can buy a little pocket notebook for
this purpose you can maybe even just
fold up a three by five card or a sheet
of paper and put it in your pocket
you'll also need to have a pen or a
pencil devoted to this task that will
ride around with you putting a notebook
in your bag or using maybe a computer
spreadsheet that won't be effective here
you want this low-tech recording device
to be something you can have access to
anytime wherever you are within a few
seconds of deciding to do so immediacy
turns out to be key here
so you walk around with a notepad and a
pen
at the start of the day write down the
date at the top of the page then put it
back in your pocket
anytime you engage in your bad behavior
don't beat yourself up about it just
pull out the notepad write down the time
of day and maybe a few words summarizing
the details of it where you were how
long you did it things like that
if you're trying to cut down on
television maybe note the start and end
time of the television watching if it's
a doughnut eating habit write down the
time place and flavor of the donut
at the end of the day
as you're about to go to sleep read over
your list of incidents
then
turn the page put them away
that is that's it
unlike unlike most tips for trying to
reduce bad habits this one actually
doesn't involve trying to quit all you
do is make a short notation every time
you do it
actually many programs aimed at things
like smoking cessation use this as a
baseline task you start by noting how
much you actually smoke for one week and
then start the intervention whatever
that is perhaps chewing nicotine
replacement gum or exercising to reduce
cravings
the goal in studies like that of course
is to identify how people can reduce
smoking below this baseline level
but the baseline procedure itself it
turns out just noting the incidents
often has a very strong effect all by
itself
cognitive scientists have identified at
least a few reasons for this the most
basic comes directly from our thinking
about these unconscious processes that
control your behavior
since the unconscious processes are
often in control of things you may not
actually be aware of how often you
engage in a particular behavior
if you're like most people if you say
start writing down a note every time you
watch television for another 30 minutes
you may be somewhat shocked to realize
just how much time you spend on that
activity
if someone is an habitual smoker they
feel a craving and they just walk
outside to have a cigarette often
without thinking about it very much
smokers sometimes report being a bit
surprised at how quickly a pack of
cigarettes seems to get used up
that's because in a very real way they
didn't decide to smoke most of them
that unconscious largely independent
independent cranial house guests did it
for them
when you make a point of writing down
the incidents in which you engaged in
your targeted bad habit you force your
conscious mind to be involved
as you do the thing whatever that is
over the course of the day you'll see
the page of your notebook getting more
full
without even trying you'll tend to
eliminate some of the unconscious
repetitions of that behavior and it will
be reduced in frequency
there's another process that's promoted
by this note-taking activity that
several researchers have explored
recently the theory is stated somewhat
loosely that self-control is like a
muscle
when you exercise a muscle you use up
its resources you you beat it up a
little bit
after the workout the muscle will be
fatigued and less useful but it will
heal and when it does heal it gets
stronger
the same thing seems to apply to our
self-control
in one set of experiments conducted by a
team led by mark mark muravin
participants were recruited and asked to
refrain from eating any sweets for two
full weeks total stop
no gradual weaning off of them just
nothing sweet at all for two weeks
this is a challenging self-control task
for almost anyone
the participants noted whenever they
slipped and ate something they weren't
supposed to just like i've urged you to
do for your bad habit
the participants were largely successful
in accomplishing this two-week cessation
all substantially reduced their
consumption of sugary foods
the really interesting results emerged
when the participants came into the lab
at the end of those two weeks for
testing they completed something called
a stop signal test
in this task you watch a computer screen
if a rectangle appears on the right side
of the screen you press a key with your
right hand as quickly as possible if the
rectangle appears on the left again left
or you sign this time with your left
hand again as quickly as possible this
is pretty simple but there's an added
wrinkle
for a randomly selected 25 percent of
the trials a soft beep sound is made
when the rectangle appears
on those trials and only on those trials
participants have to ignore it and make
no key press response
this sounds easy but it pits one part of
your brain against another
the visual motor system learns this
simple left versus right key press task
very quickly and then it gets faster and
faster as it completes more and more
trials
when the soft beep sound occurs
the voluntary conscious self-control
system has to jump in whoa stop
some people tend to be better at this
task than others that's not that
surprising what is surprising is that
the people who are better at stopping
themselves from hitting those keys have
better general self-control
when they decide to do things to change
their habits they're significantly
better at sticking with that decision
what's even more striking
is that this self-control ability is
improved after two weeks of avoiding
sugary snacks
when participants complete this test
before and after a two-week period they
generally don't improve much
but if they spent those two weeks
engaging in a self-control behavior like
restricting their diet they
significantly improve in their stop
signal test scores
okay i've urged you to be skeptical
scientists in this course and there's a
control problem in this study i've
suggested it's the self-control aspects
of the sugary snack avoidance task that
leads to the improved performance on the
stop signal test is it
or is it the actual reduction in sugar
intake that that generates that
improvement
the experimenters thought of this and
included other tasks that were demanding
for self-control abilities for instance
some participants were randomly assigned
to a hand grip task during the two weeks
instead of the sugary sweet avoidance
task they were given a spring loaded
hand strength trainer it's a v-shaped
device if you squeeze very hard you can
pull the two ends of the v together
participants in this condition were told
to squeeze it together and then hold it
there as long as they could until their
grip muscles gave out they physically
couldn't hold it shut anymore these hand
grip participants would do this twice
per day
just like avoiding sugary snacks
performing this intense exercise twice
per day involves a lot of self-control
especially after a few days a week your
hand and arm are likely to be very sore
to push yourself through the physical
discomfort involves a substantial amount
of self-control
the hand grip participants show the same
significant improvement on the stop
signal test the same one that the sugary
snack avoiders did
it seems that if you practice
self-control you improve self-control
just like a muscle
okay back to our notebook in the process
of reducing a bad habit just by writing
it down i hope i haven't oversold this
method by the way you do have to want to
reduce the frequency of the habit i'm
presuming that you aren't grabbing the
notebook and then going wild with that
bad habit trusting trusting that the
notebook will somehow magically
eliminate your desire for it it whatever
it might be
presumably you do want to quit the habit
and when you take the time to write down
that note even that brief amount of time
you're engaging in self-control
when you think about the need to take
out the notebook the
that the lists of incidents will be
growing longer and longer over the
course of the day you'll gradually come
to resist it a little longer and then a
little longer still
certainly writing down every time you
engage in some behavior makes you more
conscious of it that's a big part of why
it seems to work but you're also
exercising your self-control muscles
without really trying too hard and
improving your general self-regulation
in the process
there have been a few fmri studies that
have characterized where these
self-control muscles are located
it's not surprising that when people are
engaged in a successful signal stop
behavior the superior medial and
precentral frontal cortexes both show
greater activation
these frontal lobes of ours are
associated with a lot of things problem
solving creativity strategic thinking
the frontal lobes are also strongly
associated with regulating the rest of
the brain in terms of things like
impulse control and avoiding overly
risky behavior it's actually one of the
last areas of the brain to finish
developing
we used to think of the brain as being
finished with its primary development by
the late teen years
but some recent work has suggested
otherwise between 18 and 22 years of age
there's a surge of development in these
frontal lobes
specifically there's a large increase in
the production of myelin a fatty
insulating substance that increases
neuronal efficiency an increase in this
white matter right there in the frontal
lobes
during the same period of time
people get much better at self-control
in general
most people presume it's this
development that leads to the reduction
in the high risk impulsive behaviors
that are commonly associated with the
teen years
okay
what else can we do to improve pat's bad
habits or rather reduce those bad habits
there's a member of my family who has a
bad habit of picking in his fingernails
it's a grooming habit
you see a little irregularity in your
fingernail and you pick at it to make it
smooth again
fortunately
sometimes that creates another little
edge so you pick at that if you do this
long enough you end up with very sore
fingers it's a bad habit one that i can
certainly imagine our bad house guests
might have as well
whenever i notice the nail picking
behavior occurring i say hey don't pick
your nails
sometimes i just reach over and touch
his hand make eye contact and that's
sufficient
he always stops when i call his
attention to it but i can see the
internal mental battle it creates
the part of his brain that wants to pick
those nails is still pushing him to do
it the only reason he's not picking at
his nails is that now there's another
mental process
probably those frontal lobes holding
that unconscious nail picking process at
bay
it's very hard for a human brain to
choose
not to think about something
let's actually try this for the next 30
seconds or so try not to think about
pink elephants
okay you're probably thinking about a
pink elephant right now because i just
said it but clear that from your mind
now don't think about it let's try this
for 10 seconds
go
if you're like most people you just
failed at this task
most people start by thinking about
something else i've been watching tennis
so i thought about a tennis match
a fuzzy green tennis ball sitting on a
tennis court there's grass on some
tennis courts
hay is a type of grass sometimes hay is
eaten by
pink elephants
though well
the human brain is remarkably good at
making associative links between things
at finding those links even when they're
somewhat remote
it's an unconscious tendency that we all
have that we really can't fully turn off
if you think about something that you
don't want to think about you are in a
sense already thinking about it
the same thing happens when we try to
not think about engaging in some
habitual behavior
calling attention to the behavior will
help
and your inhibitory self-control ability
will get stronger with that exercise
we've established that but there's a
better way
instead of turning off an existing
associative link which we can't really
do anyway you can create an alternative
associative link and make it stronger
strong enough that it eventually takes
over control of your behaviors
most people's intuitions about reducing
a bad habit like this is to
well just stop it
actually that's what we've talked about
up until this point with that notebook
method
call attention to the behavior whenever
it occurs and then reduce its
frequencies
this is effective but what's much more
effective leads to our next brain based
tip
to stop a bad habit you need to replace
it with something else
the goal of this training procedure
remember is not to just temporarily
change behavior but to ultimately change
the underlying mental processes that
drive a problematic habit in the first
place
from this perspective it's not enough to
just prevent the behavior from being
performed you need to create a new
automatic unconscious process that will
take the place of the problematic one
there's a lot of evidence supporting
this assertion
one of my favorite studies of it was
conducted by marika adriance and her
collaborators they asked participants to
identify situations that triggered the
performance of a bad habit
for instance when i am bored sometimes i
pick at my fingernails when i feel
anxious i tend to go to the kitchen for
a sugary snack
when i feel cranky i am more likely to
start an argument over something trivial
it's easy to think about
to think of these for any bad habit that
you might have it always starts with
some trigger
that gets that unconscious processing
going
okay so people in this study identified
their triggers that's an important step
the next step is the critical one
rather than just deciding to not engage
in the bad habit the participants were
asked to come up with an alternative
behavior and to intentionally pursue
that when the trigger showed up
something like when i feel bored i will
play piano
when i feel anxious
i will eat an apple
when i feel cranky i'll go for a
walk this is a true experiment that was
conducted here so half of the
participants were assigned to this
condition the one in which they picked
alternative trigger responses the other
half of the participants were randomly
assigned to the control condition they
did not use this technique
the experimenters found that the focus
on associating an alternative behavior
with the trigger resulted in a
significantly greater reduction in the
habitual behavior
the researchers also performed a variety
of tests exploring how this change
occurred they presented participants in
both the experimental and the control
conditions with a brief presentation of
the trigger word on a computer screen so
in the example situations i described
the words might have been boredom or
anxious
the trigger word would appear and it
would vanish and then another word would
appear
sometimes that second word was just
scrambled letters wasn't a word at all
really sometimes the word was unrelated
to the bad habit behavior sometimes the
word was the bad habit
finally sometimes the word was
the alternative behavior
this is kind of a complicated design but
the results can be summarized pretty
simply
when you form an alternative an
alternate intention
uh an alternate behavioral association
with that trigger that usually causes
the bad habit
your brain changes its internal
association structure
after forming and practicing the
alternate association your brain starts
to process the new action faster if it
happens quickly enough that new behavior
will tend to be triggered instead of the
bad habit behavior
many studies point to a particular
region in the left temporal part of the
cortex that's responsible for processing
word meanings
in addition to recognizing the
individual words this region of the
brain our language system processes the
meanings of the words based on the
things with which that word is
associated
if you see the word baseball and bat
the second word means a very different
thing than if you see vampire and bat
when we read a word it activates a whole
host of concepts that are related to it
again it does all of this quickly and
unconsciously
in addition to activating words it also
seems to activate actions actions that
are associated with the word
if you read the word board
you'll not be able to not think about
behaviors that you tend to pursue when
you're bored
when you feel that trigger sensation the
associated behavior just automatically
enters your mind and influences your
behavior
so with pat the bad house guest you
shouldn't just request
a stopping of the bad habit behavior
you should suggest an alternative
behavior and encourage ways to engage in
that behavior instead
to change your own behaviors you should
do the same thing
think through what you tend to be
thinking about right before you engage
in your bad habit
then come up with a good alternative
something that would be healthier or
just generally better
envision the trigger feeling coming to
you and then imagine performing the
alternative behavior instead some some
work suggests that it's a good idea to
state these intentions aloud
whenever i feel cranky i will go for a
walk for 15 minutes
writing it down might also help to make
it more salient for you might help you
to cement that new association more
strongly
actually it might be a good idea to
combine this with our notebook method
write down not only when you did engage
in the bad behavior also write down the
times when you felt the trigger and
engaged in the alternative better
behavior
at the end of the day as you review your
notes think through those associations
again also take a moment to praise
yourself for the times when you did the
right thing
actually that self-praise leads to our
next tip
if you want to change your house guest's
behavior
you might consider using positive and
negative reinforcement to shape behavior
it can feel silly to use that on
yourself but there's good evidence that
it works
let's explore this in some more detail
if after you engage in some behavior any
behavior something positive happens it
will reinforce the behavior you'll be
more likely to perform that same
behavior in the future
if on the other hand after you engage in
some behavior something bad happens
it will punish the behavior you'll be
less likely to perform that same action
in the future
positive reinforcement is when something
pleasant gets added to your experience
after you perform a behavior if when pat
picks up the laundry
i reward with a cookie pat will be more
likely to pick up the laundry in the
future
negative reinforcement is when something
aversive gets removed after you perform
a behavior note that negative
reinforcement is not the same thing as
punishment although many people think
that it is
let's think about negative reinforcement
imagine that i give pat an angry look
every few minutes when the laundry's on
the floor
if after it's picked up i stop giving
angry looks then i have removed
something aversive in response to pat's
behavior pat will be more likely to pick
up the laundry in the future
positive punishment is when something
negative is added to your experience
after you perform a behavior
if pat puts dirty laundry on the floor
and i give an angry look afterward pat
will be less likely to repeat that
action in the future so that's positive
punishment negative punishment is when
something positive gets removed after
you perform a behavior maybe i often
smile at pat's and offer cookies
if when pat puts dirty laundry on the
floor i stop doing that then i've taken
away something positive pat will be less
likely to perform that behavior in the
future
in principle
you can use any one of these four tools
on yourself
at an informational level they're all
sort of the same they're like flip sides
of the same coin
in general in order to promote more
general and long-lasting learning
a lot of research suggests that you
should focus on the reinforcement side
of things
imagine i have a bad habit of leaving
the television on when i depart for work
in the morning i want to change my
behavior to lessen the incidence of that
habit
what i need to do is make a little
contract with myself
if i remember to turn everything off
when i go to work starting tomorrow
i get to have a cookie when i come home
that seems downright silly to me at some
level why should i need to give myself a
cookie to change my behavior should i
just decide to turn the tv off when i
leave
but remember i'm not trying to change my
conscious behavior
i am to use the language of a
behaviorist like bf skinner i'm shaping
the behavior of my unconscious action
control systems
the cookie isn't for the conscious part
of my brain that cookie is for the part
of my brain that controls things
unconsciously
a wide range of studies have been
conducted on self-administered
reinforcement that's what this is called
over the course of really several
decades people have been studying this
students have used it to improve study
habits dieters have used to improve to
improve their healthy eating habits
people with phobias have used this type
of system to train themselves to not
avoid the thing that makes them afraid
you can pick almost anything make that
contract with yourself and then change
your behavior
i should make two comments about how to
use this most effectively
first you shouldn't expect to change a
change to take place overnight
one hallmark of behavioral shaping like
this
is that it can be a slow process it
might be several weeks before you reach
that final behavior state that you seek
often behavioral scientists who use
these techniques to train animals to
perform complex sequences of actions
will import employ something called a
gradual shaping process
if you want to teach yourself the habit
of eating healthy all day long it might
not be best to start by training
yourself to eat healthy for
for one meal of the day
maybe breakfast
once you reliably achieve that just
getting one healthy meal accomplished
you could then focus on adding in lunch
eating then dinner and snacking perhaps
last this kind of training process is
slow
but the good news is that once it's set
unlearning the training will also
function slowly eventually you won't
have to re reinforce yourself all the
time maybe just every once in a while in
order to maintain the learning you
should definitely maintain that at least
periodic reinforcement for good behavior
the reinforcer doesn't have to be a
cookie of course actually if you're
training yourself to eat healthier it
shouldn't be the reinforcer you can
reward yourself with anything that makes
you feel good maybe watch a favorite tv
show
take a nice walk maybe even just take a
few minutes to sit and think about how
great you are a figurative pat on the
back can be remarkably good as a
positive reinforcer
a second issue you consider
as you should consider as you're
undertaking this is the need for
compliance with your contract this is a
persistent problem in this type of
research in which people make this
contract with themselves and then
don't stick to it
maybe i decide that i won't eat a cookie
unless i remember to turn off the tv but
then i forget i leave the tv on that
night i just decide to have a cookie
anyway
in some studies up to 40 percent of
participants report this sort of
non-compliance with the strategy
firstly it's bad for the training for
obvious reasons remember it's your
unconscious house guest who learns from
the reinforcement if you give that
reinforcement when it isn't warranted it
will dilute the positive benefits of the
whole process
in this lecture we've considered a
variety of ways to train your
intracranial house guest
if our unconscious mind functions
independently then the best way to alter
its function is often to consider it as
an independent entity as if you're
working to change the behavior not of
yourself but of another person
by noting when you engage in a bad habit
even without trying to reduce it you'll
make the behavior more salient and it
will likely be reduced in frequency
by replacing the bad habit with some
other positive behavior and then
associating it with a trigger that
causes the bad habit you can again
further reduce any bad habit perhaps
more importantly you can increase the
frequency of good
behaviors finally by pulling out the big
guns of positive and negative
reinforcement you can further shape your
unconscious habit-based behaviors to be
whatever you want them to be
habits can seem like small things be too
unimportant to deserve much attention
when someone does something bad they'll
often play it off as oh yeah sorry
that's just a bad habit i have
when we talk about examples like turning
off the tv eating healthy snacks it
similarly seems like this isn't one of
the biggest or most important of topics
but it is important
most of our behaviors
most of the actions that we perform in
any given day are
habits
aristotle said that we are what we
repeatedly do
excellence then is not an act but a
habit
jim ryan one of the greatest distance
runners in american history said that
motivation is what gets you started
habit is what keeps you going
if we can fix our habitual tendencies
we can fix our lives we can make
ourselves our lives whatever we want
them to be